I kind of compare it with being at a
giant dog park some of them love it like
you start giving them armpit scratches
and they're just like giant dogs they
just start rolling around and they're
flying all around you but these animals
are huge people are intimidated by them
but once you once you learn their
behavior they're just right into you
right away they just look at you like a
big chew toy
I could never see myself living anywhere
other than the Pacific Northwest
I could literally spend every single day
of the rest of my life and never travel
anywhere other than Vancouver Island and
I would still never have enough time to
see this whole place my first
introduction to the ocean would have
definitely come from my mom she's means
the ceiling right there later on in life
realize it is a pretty unique experience
to get to go and spend time with these
animals on a regular basis sea lions are
large intelligent animal and they're
very sensitive of what your intentions
are and and how they choose interact
with you is totally their choice if
you're comfortable and and they're
inquisitive they'll come and they'll
chew on your fans or they come up and
they chew on the edge of your mask or
give you a big kisses on the lips or big
hugs they wrapped your their fins around
you and give you a big hug
people get sketched out about it like
I've had lots people contact me and be
like don't you think those things are
aggressive just because in animals
putting its mouth on you doesn't mean
it's doing it in a harmful way they
don't have hands they can to explore
their world with anything other than
their mouth there's people that spend
now a lot of money to travel to the
other side of the planet to watch a
group a large migratory animals in
Africa or something say and here I can
just go out on my boat and it's not
something I take for granted at all
anymore having the opportunity to do
this if you're afraid of coming down and
going and swimming in the ocean because
of sharks you should be terrified to
make a piece of toast 400 people died
last year from defective toasters
whereas less than 10 did from sharks
this is the first large shark expedition
like this in the Western Gulf will be
tagged in hammerhead sharks tiger sharks
and mako sharks trying to understand how
they're leveraging the Gulf and their
birthing mating and full migratory
patterns will be getting up every day
just before dawn the fishing team will
be going out getting all of our lines
rigged and ready to go and then we'll
get the ship in position with a lift in
the water and we'll be looking to
capture bring sharks back to the lift
lift them up out of the water and once
we do that a whole team of scientists
from a half dozen institutions will
circle around the shark and will conduct
12 research projects in about 15 minutes
then release the shark in open source
the tracking to the world so that
everyone can follow it
what we're finding is that these massive
sharks have huge huge movements across
the ocean we have one of these white
sharks Lydia who's traveled over 35,000
miles in just two years very very
regular for these sharks to be swimming
a thousand miles a month which is why
it's so important to figure out where
they go
we're losing 200,000 sharks a day for
shark fin soup a hundred million a year
you know people need to understand an
ocean with no sharks means an ocean with
no fish they are the lion the balance
keeper of the ocean and if they are not
there the whole food chain collapses
this is a simple battle we got to solve
the puzzle these sharks lives to make
sure they flourish and make a difference
for the future
a narwhals horn is actually an enlarged
tooth and not a horn at all today we're
talking about narwhals unicorns of the
sea nice shirt
my grandfather Jacques Cousteau studied
and explored the Earth's ocean I do too
and our submarine is in Arctic waters
searching for the narwhal oh he's a
beauty
a nor walls can grow up to 17 feet in
length and their front tooth can grow up
to 10 feet in length it's the only
straight tusks in the world but
typically these are only found on males
and are actually full of up to 10
million nerve endings helping the
narwhal detect pressure salt levels and
even temperature in the water
here's an interesting fact a narwhal
tusk is flexible it can bend about one
foot in any direction without breaking
it was originally thought that these
tusks were for dueling but a new theory
suggests they're for attracting a mate
narwhals don't migrate like other whale
species
they spend their entire lives in icy
Arctic waters hunting squid fish and
crap if you want to see one live you'll
have to come up North because noir walls
don't thrive in captivity rather they
die some animals we humans just can't
tame
to be able to be doing science while
you're out there on the surfboard
surfing down the face of the wave it's
just such a fleeting moment it's
incredible to actually be able to do it
smartphone is a surfboard fit you clip
it on the bottom of your board you go
out for your surf session it has
technology that measures ocean pH
salinity ocean temperature and very
detailed wave characteristics so there
will be an enormous amount of data
the reason these parameters are
important is because they are shifting
directly as a result of climate change
we have detailed information about the
deep ocean but very limited accurate
information about the near shore
satellites can't be really accurate with
data in that narrow zone and the other
way is ocean buoys and they are just not
deployed at the coast bingo
smart fin can fill that gap collecting
oceanic data is a very time-consuming
expensive process this is like you just
need to know how to surf the data moves
from your fin to your phone via
bluetooth and then from your phone it
goes up to our servers where
everything's processed
I had to develop sensors that don't
affect the surfboard
nobody's gonna surf a fin that is not a
standard foil aside from that LED right
there is blinking that tells you that
there's like some sort of technology now
you wouldn't know the difference so
we've got a test tank set up now and
we're just trying to look at the
precision and accuracy of the instrument
itself things are looking pretty
promising
as a scientist it's pretty exciting to
be able to get data over these different
time and space scales I mean the fact
that you can go out and surf and
contribute to understanding what's
actually happening out there is
incredible I'm not a surfer I know
nothing about surfing I know I look like
a surfer but um I'm not surfers are very
influential and care deeply about the
environment and want to be talking about
it
so smartphone is just a tool to do that
in a more concrete way morale is kind of
like the trees of a forest they're just
the backbone of the whole tropical
ecosystem and if they disappear were in
a lot of trouble my name is Kenny de
Meyer I'm the founder of the coral
restoration foundation the reason I'm
doing this I was been growing up diving
spent a lot of time in the water at what
I basically watched the coral reefs
dying as the reefs died that fish didn't
come back and I realized I'm tired of
watching it die I need to do something
about it and so I developed this whole
idea of growing corals in an offshore
nursery and replanting them on the reef
so you're kind of like a farmer I'm a
farmer yeah we grow corals just like a
farm there's a good time of the year to
plant and there's a harvest time and we
have five offshore nurseries in the keys
each tree can hold 100 corals we start
with little fragments that we collect
and after six to nine months maybe a
year that fragment has turned into a
colony that might have a hundred
centimeters of growth on it we cut that
off and then we plant it out on the reef
so we just harvested some corals and
we're gonna take them out to pickle's
reef right now and plant them we've got
a couple thousand of them out there that
we've already planted and gonna add some
more it is a bit of gardening when you
put the corals back out on the reef
you're saying yeah I think that would
look nice over there and that one looked
nice over there and some of its based on
what used to be there and what should be
there and that's how we do our planting
we planted twenty thousand already this
year we'll plant twenty-five thousand
next year those corals will probably
spawn next year part of the long-range
goal is get the corals reproducing on
their own
I'm excited every time I get in the
water whether I'm going to work in the
nursery or whether I'm planting corals
or just looking for new areas to plant a
lot of people said oh you can never do
that it'll never work can't do it on a
big enough scale and I think I've proven
that that can be done and if we can
train enough people and teach enough
people in other places I think we can
really see a significant turnaround
another day another twirl